[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas de la semana en nuestro
continente relacionadas con la pandemia
del cob y 19 a continuación les presento
algunos de los temas que vamos a tratar
en nuestra consulta con el médico
tendremos a una especialista invitada
con quien hablaremos del sub linaje de
la variante delta recientemente
encontrada hablaremos también del
aumento de los casos en europa a pesar
de haber tenido una rápida vacunación y
de haber tomado medidas durante el
verano boreal como esto también puede
servir de espejo para américa latina
para no repetir este mismo escenario
también iremos hasta canadá para conocer
la situación de ese país en donde
recientemente fue aprobada la
implementación de un pasaporte de
vacunación para poder viajar tanto
dentro como fuera del país asimismo
daremos un vistazo al avance de la
vacunación y el impulso que puede tener
allí la vacunación después de la compra
de un lote de 2.9 millones de dosis de
vacunas que van a ser utilizadas
solamente para menores de edad
ya hablaremos también de brasil allí el
manejo que le ha dado el presidente ya
ir bolso nado a la pandemia de kobe 19
ha sido motivo de críticas una comisión
parlamentaria tras una investigación de
seis meses recomendó imponer cargos
contra el mandatario por sus decisiones
para hacer frente a la crisis sanitaria
que en ese país ya ha dejado más de
600.000 fallecidos es la segunda cifra
de víctimas mortales más alta del mundo
pues comenzamos el programa y lo hacemos
precisamente hablando de números de
cifras vamos a ver como cerró esta
semana el panorama de los contagios y
también de las víctimas mortales que
deja el kobe 19 en nuestro continente y
comenzamos en mexico allí los casos
alcanzaron ya los 3.7 millones de casos
confirmados y los fallecidos son más de
285 mil personas
colombia cierra la semana con más de 4.9
millones de casos confirmados se
aproxima ya a los 5 millones y más de
126 mil personas han fallecido en perú
en los casos alcanzaron los 2.1 millones
y los fallecidos ya superan 299 mil
a los 200.000 para finalizar tenemos las
cifras de republica dominicana los casos
confirmados están por encima de los
373.000 y los fallecidos ya pasan de los
vamos a comenzar en el caribe cuba se
prepara para darle la bienvenida
nuevamente a los turistas y así
reactivar uno de los pilares
fundamentales de su economía el gobierno
de la isla levantó la medida de la
cuarentena obligatoria para quienes
ingresan al país así como el requisito
de una prueba negativa de pcr las
autoridades también indicaron que
ofrecerán vacunas para los visitantes
extranjeros el informe es de ariana
villacorta
tras sufrir una caída del 94 por ciento
en el número de visitantes entre enero y
mayo de 2021 'cuba reabre sus puertas al
turismo uno de los pilares de su
economía y lo hace dándole facilidades a
los viajeros cuba elimina la cuarentena
obligatoria de los viajeros
internacionales al arribo a partir del 7
de noviembre ya hemos adelantado una
semana la eliminación de la policial en
cuba esto no significa capacidad de
crisis noviembre se ha dado en la
frontera la frontera se abre en el día
inicial pero las personas que arriben al
país del 7 al 15 ya no realizarán 40
el ministro de turismo cubano también
confirmó que a partir del 15 de
noviembre dejará de ser obligatorio
presentar una prueba pcr al ingresar a
la isla además se restablecerá el
transporte interprovincial eliminando
los permisos para circular entre
provincias también vuelven los servicios
de trenes nacionales y el servicio
marítimo a la isla de la juventud por
otra parte el gobierno de miguel díaz
canel permitió la reapertura de centros
culturales aunque con un aforo limitada
en el caso de las librerías bibliotecas
museo y galería reanudará ya de hecho lo
están así es sus servicios a la
población en los horarios habituales
siempre manteniendo las medidas
higiénico-sanitarias y limitando el
número de participante el 50 por fin
apelamos también a la responsabilidad
y finalmente se eliminó el toque de
queda nocturno que regía desde las 10 de
la noche a las 5 de la mañana
estas medidas se toman luego de una
campaña de vacunación con las
inoculaciones producidas en el país
abdalá soberana 2 y soberana plus donde
6.8 millones de personas de una
población de 11.2 millones ya recibió
las tres dosis necesarias contra el cob
y 19 vacunas que además serán ofrecidas
a los extranjeros que llegan a la isla
veamos ahora cómo ha avanzado la
vacunación en el continente americano a
continuación les presento el porcentaje
de población con esquema de vacunación
completo en algunos países de nuestro
continente comenzamos en méxico en donde
el 40,0 1% de la población ya tiene el
esquema completo costa rica alcanzó para
esta semana el 49 18% de la población
colombia finaliza con 38 57% perú el 43
punto 29% y finalizamos con chile el
líder de la región que llego al 74 punto
81 por ciento
y méxico comenzó la vacunación en
adolescentes entre los 12 y los 17 años
que padecen enfermedades crónicas el
país se encuentra en un momento en el
que está registrando su punto más bajo
de casos confirmados desde el inicio de
la pandemia de kobe 19 el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador criticó a la
ms por no haber aprobado hasta el
momento las vacunas cancino y sputnik ve
precisamente esta última la vacuna
sputnik de fabricada en rusa en rusia va
a comenzar a ser producida también en
mexico veamos
méxico ya vacuna menores de edad de
entre 12 y 17 años con enfermedades
crónicas y el gobierno dice que el país
se acerca a su punto mínimo absoluto de
casos con 19 tras 11 semanas
consecutivas de reducción en el número
de contagios menos del 1% de los casos
estimados son casos activos y estos
representan 32 mil 136 casos en la
hospitalización que es otro indicador
muy importante sobre todo en la parte
grave de enfermedad covif vemos que
también hemos ido con una reducción
sostenida y si comparamos con el punto
máximo de toda la epidemia en méxico
tenemos una reducción de 81 por ciento
en el índice de hospitalización el
índice de camas cobit ocupadas según la
organización a world in data se han
administrado más de 113 millones de
dosis de la vacuna contra el cob y 19 y
más de 51 millones de personas han sido
inmunizadas con el esquema completo en
el país azteca esto representa más del
40 por ciento de una población de más de
130 millones
la gran mayoría de estas inoculaciones
se han realizado con las vacunas de
cancino sputnik que aún no han sido
aprobadas por la organización mundial de
la salud por lo que el presidente
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador
criticó al organismo y no puede ver
de por medio ninguna
justificación de carácter político o
ideológico
sería éste un absurdo
la oración mundial de la salud actúe a
partir
criterios políticos
yo pienso más que
s
de cydia
pese a esto méxico empezará a producir
la vacuna rusa sputnik de que tampoco
cuenta con la aprobación de la unión
europea ni de eeuu esto tras un acuerdo
entre los laboratorios de biológicos y
reactivos de méxico con el fondo ruso de
inversión directa con la finalidad de
acelerar la vacunación en el país
y desde méjico nos vamos ahora hasta
canadá veamos algunas de las cifras
generales de este país para comprender
cómo está la situación en este país
tiene ya casos confirmados las cifras ya
ronda en los 1.7 millones mientras que
los fallecidos ya alcanzan los 28.000 de
otra parte los vacunados con un esquema
completo alcanzan en canadá el 73 puntos
29 por ciento
y bueno también hubo otras noticias
destacadas en canadá entre ellas la
obligatoriedad de la vacunación para los
parlamentarios una medida que no ha
escapado de la controversia en ese país
también la imposición de un pasaporte
para que los ciudadanos puedan
desplazarse entre las diferentes
provincias canadienses y también hacia
otros países vamos a conectar con
danielle faura ls periodista que se
encuentra en las ciudades de toronto
para conocer más detalles de lo que ha
sucedido allá a lo largo de la semana y
comienzo preguntándole en daniele por el
tema de la vacunación obligatoria para
los parlamentarios para poder acceder a
la cámara de los comunes
claro que si santiago el parlamento
canadiense ha decidido que darán
adelante la cámara de los comunes tienen
que tener sus funcionarios totalmente
vacunados con doble vacunación y
pasaporte de vacunación tendrán que
mostrarlo al ingreso a este recinto
muchos están en desacuerdo como el
congresista del partido conservador
blade white hart quien está diciendo que
esto atenta contra la libertad y la
democracia en canadá ya que ellos fueron
elegidos democráticamente el pasado mes
de septiembre e iniciarán labores el
próximo 22 de noviembre así que es una
batalla que no tiene mucho futuro ya que
siete de los nueve diputados que deciden
las reglas del parlamento han dicho sí
daniele quiero preguntar ahora por ese
pasaporte de vacunación para que los
ciudadanos puedan moverse entre las
diferentes provincias canadienses y
también fuera del país
y ciertamente el pasaporte de vacunación
ya es una realidad en canadá es una idea
del primer ministro georges team trudeau
que va a hacer extensivo a las 10
provincias de canadá va a servir para
que los ciudadanos los residentes
canarios se puedan salir del país o se
puedan jugar dentro del país en avión en
tren o entrar a ciertos recintos el gran
desafío para el primer ministro es hacer
el lobby para que este pasaporte sea
aceptado en otros países de momento se
le recomienda a las personas que van a
usar el pasaporte que aparte del
pasaporte carguen sus dos certificados
de vacunación para que no tengan
problemas hasta que lo funcione y fuera
del país sea aceptado como es aceptado
el pasaporte canadiense en muchos países
danielle y para el cierre hablemos del
tema de la vacunación allí adquirieron
2.9 millones de dosis de vacunas que van
a ser destinadas para los menores de
edad como está avanzando el proceso
canadá recibirá 2.3 millones de vacunas
de facer como parte de un acuerdo
pediátrico que hicieron en la primavera
pasada a los niños que van a ser parte
de este piloto son niños entre las
edades de 5 y 11 años primero tiene que
haber una aprobación de salud canadá que
es el ente gubernamental que hace esta
aprobación aquí en este país y lo cierto
es que hay correos electrónicos que ya
están llegando a padres de familia donde
se les piden que hagan parte de este
plan voluntario para los niños no se
sabe si todavía va a ser un plan de
vacunación doble o simplemente va a ser
una sola vacuna lo cierto es que ya
muchos padres están firmando porque
quieren que sus hijos hagan parte de
este plan piloto porque se están viendo
algunos brotes en colegios y en jardines
aquí en toronto
daniele favor a muchas gracias por este
reporte desde la ciudad de toronto
daniele debutando hoy en el programa que
en kobe 19 la semana en américa y está
con nosotros también la doctora roxana
trejo ella es médica cirujana magister
en salud pública y epidemiología se
encuentra en la ciudad de mexico y está
con nosotros sea para nuestra consulta
habitual aquí en el programa doctora
como siempre un gusto saludarla gracias
por estar con nosotros y comienzo por
preguntarle por el caso de europa y de
rusia en donde ha habido recientemente
un aumento de los casos de contagio de
kobe 19 pese a que tuvieron en planes de
vacunación muy rigurosos muy exigentes y
que eliminaron algunas de las medidas de
bioseguridad en el verano ya hace varios
meses atrás esto puede servirle de
espejo américa latina' qué piensa usted
bueno muchas gracias por la invitación
santiago te agradezco mucho nuevamente
estar en tu estudio y con tus seguidores
pues lo que está ocurriendo en rusia es
algo que nos puede vislumbrar lo que
puede ocurrir si el tema de vacunación
no se lleva de una manera homogénea y si
detectamos o tenemos pues personas que
deciden no vacunarse lo que está
ocurriendo rusia es que los casos están
aumentando día a día las muertes también
y tiene que ver mucho también con el
porcentaje de vacunación que ellos
tienen hoy no es un porcentaje de
vacunación que no es muy alto es un
porcentaje de vacunación que no les da
esta inmunidad colectiva que deberían de
tener por país y que al final no tiene
que ver con un tema de producción de
vacuna porque ellos también dan vacuna o
venta en vacuna hacia otros países
tienen que ver más con un tema de
sensibilización en la población y lo que
está ocurriendo hoy es lo que puede
suceder y también las medidas las
medidas que se tienen que tomar y que
debemos de seguir hoy de protección pues
también están abajo y por esta razón
está en esta situación russian a este
momento bueno un ejemplo sin duda alguna
doctora para la región de américa latina
a las vacaciones que se vienen para
diciembre para la navidad hablemos ahora
de otra noticia que fue destacada a lo
largo de esta semana que es el hallazgo
de un sub linaje de la variante delta
comienzo por preguntarle lo más básico
que es un sub linaje y qué significa
esto dentro de la variante delta que ya
sabemos lo contagiosa que puede ser
bueno en los sistemas que se tienen en
algunos países no en todos pero hay
sistemas muy robustos de detección de
vacunas y de seguimiento a estas
variantes sabemos el que la brillante
ventaja no es un nuevo virus simplemente
es la mutación de esa variante ancestral
original del sars con dos que fue en
2019 si la cual ha ido mutando sea para
fortalecerse para disminuir sus
fortalezas y está este tema su blindaje
pues son estas variantes que salen de
otra variante que no puede ser venta no
que se detectó es que existe como una
mutación en la variante delta que esta
mutación puede haber un aumento en los
casos que puede ser que exista un
aumento en la transmisibilidad todavía
no no se tiene certeza de esto se ha
observado algunos casos este específicos
en algunos países como reino unido
algunos también en perdón en eeuu muy
pocos pero al final no se observa que
sea una variante de preocupación o está
categorizada está pues este sub linaje
todavía como una variante de interés no
exactamente con una variante de
preocupación que sería cuando rebasa
está pues estando un veedor de personas
contagiadas cuando los resultados en los
tratamientos cambian totalmente y cuando
al final podemos tener que cambiar
medidas sanitarias es es una brillante
que hay que seguirla es una variante que
están observando y el que creo que el
tema es que se cuentan con esos sistemas
que detectan ese tipo de cambios en
estas variantes que tenemos y bueno no
ha rebasado la capacidad que tenía del
está en su momento de dar transmisión y
por supuesto la consecuencia la
mortalidad es simplemente observar que
está teniendo mutaciones y que hay que
seguirla para que esto no cambie hay que
detener la transmisión porque lo que
tenemos claro santiago es que las
variantes ocurren cuando la gente
enferma entonces el tema hoy es que
podamos detener los contagios para no
empezar a tener estos blindajes más
variantes hay que seguir entonces
haciéndole seguimiento entonces a este
su blindaje para ver cómo se desarrolla
este tema pasemos ahora a hablar de otro
tema destacado esta semana también en el
área médica y científica doctora y es no
un sub linaje estamos hablando ahora sí
de una variante la adie 4.2 qué
características tiene que se sabe en el
mundo científico y médico de esta nueva
variante y si tenemos que preocuparnos
ya también así como nos tenemos que
preocupar de la variante delta
pues mira sé que preocuparse en relación
a que vemos cómo se están fortaleciendo
estas variantes no no están disminuyendo
o sea si tú observas puede ser que al
menos esta variante todavía no está
categorizada tampoco como preocupación
pero pudiera existir de esta misma
variante una mutación que entonces si
pudiera entrar en estas variantes de
preocupación e igual que este tema de su
blindaje en esta variante también delta
pero el tema hoy es que si ha habido un
aumento de casos por este tipo de
variante tampoco ha rebasado la
capacidad que delta ha tenido cuando
cuando se encontró y se detectó en
específicamente en israel pero al final
este es un tema perdón de la india- este
es un tema importante en relación a
seguir haciendo pruebas para poder
detectar y detener algunos cambios lo
único que ha ocurrido con esta variante
es que hay un aumento en los casos no
tan desproporcionado como la variante
delta pero que sí es parte de estas
mutaciones que están teniendo estas
variantes bueno esto sin duda lo que nos
dice doctora es que tenemos que seguir
en el pie de lucha contra contra el
coronavirus a pesar del avance de la
vacunación a pesar de los cuidados
y también destacado esta semana doctores
quiero quiero que comentemos al respecto
y es ese anuncio de la fed en eeuu que
aprobó la combinación de vacunas en ese
país para reforzar el programa de
vacunación y también de cara a mejorar
las cifras en cuanto a la cifra de
perdón a las dosis de refuerzo o tercera
dosis cuáles son sus impresiones al
respecto sobre este tema de la
combinación de vacunas
pues mira lo que ha ocurrido en relación
a la combinación de vacunas por suerte
por supuesto existen ya estudios que se
están llevando a cabo en este momento
hay algunos resultados de ellos que nos
arrojan que podemos combinar pero yo
creo que también tiene que ver con el
tema de estos booster que al menos el
gobierno de eeuu con joe biden dio como
un impulso no en relación a que hay que
ponerse una tercera dosis hay que
proteger pero también la sda y el mismo
cd se pusieron en la mesa que está
tercer dosis esta tercer dosis sea más
en personas de mayores de 65 años en
personas que tienen comorbilidades que
el tema hoy es poder contar con personas
que tengan dos dosis de esta vacuna sea
combinada o sea exclusiva dependiendo de
los estudios que vayan saliendo pero que
el tema es que hay que ir avanzando y
hay que ir impulsando a que tengamos más
personas con un esquema completo
entonces el tema ha sido la dificultad
no en eeuu exactamente sino en otros
países la dificultad para contar con
primero con la primera dosis pero
después continuar y poder repetir el
esquema completo de una misma vacuna o
sea el tema de la combinación ese va a
ser el futuro es muy improbable que
podamos mantener un sistema de
vacunación para kobe 19 combinando
vacunas con lo difícil que es la
accesibilidad para algunos países en
eeuu pues normalmente tienen 5 vacunas
por personas a la capacidad instalada
que tiene vacunación es muy alta y el el
problema ha sido que la vacuna no está a
más arriba de las 55 500 pues doctora
trajo muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros en el programa gracias por
explicarnos estos temas destacados de la
semana en el área científica y médica
muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros vamos a avanzar con otros temas
que tenemos para esta emisión hablamos
de la comisión parlamentaria de
investigación de brasil que recomendó
imputar cargos contra el presidente ya
ir bolsonaro por su manejo de la crisis
sanitaria derivada de la pandemia
después de seis meses de investigación
la comisión presentó un reporte con
dichas recomendaciones veamos
crímenes premeditados en la gestión de
la pandemia fue una de las conclusiones
a las que llegó la comisión
parlamentaria de investigación del
senado tras meses de investigación sobre
el manejo de la crisis sanitaria del
presidente brasileño jair bolsonaro el
informe recomienda imputar 10 cargos
entre los que figuran crímenes contra la
humanidad uso inadecuado de los fondos
públicos incitación al crimen y
prevaricación delito que hace referencia
a cuando una autoridad dicta una
resolución a sabiendas de que es injusta
o contraria a la ley el borrador inicial
también incluía el genocidio contra los
pueblos indígenas punto que al final se
excluyó de la causa liderada por el
senador progresista renan calheiros
quien recordó el dolor de las víctimas
hoy no debemos hablar pero escuche a las
600 3.324 víctimas a través de estas
impactantes declaraciones en la cpi uno
de ellos dijo no superamos el duelo en
silencio hagan un informe que exprese lo
sucedido la investigación trata temas
como la falta de oxígeno en manaos los
retrasos en la compra de vacunas y los
discursos de bolsonaro en contra de los
confinamientos luego de darse a conocer
la publicación
el presidente que se sigue resistiendo a
recibir la vacuna desconocido las
acusaciones
sabemos que no somos culpables de
absolutamente nada
sabemos que hicimos lo correcto desde el
principio
brasil suma más de 600.000 muertes por
el virus sólo por detrás de eeuu por lo
que ahora las víctimas piden
responsabilidades aunque nada garantiza
que la acusación prospere ya que tiene
que pasar por el fiscal general cercano
al presidente por el momento tras la
publicación del veredicto final de la
cpi este será votado el próximo martes
bueno y las tengo más cifras cifras
generales de la situación en venezuela
este país cierra esta semana ya con 396
mil casos confirmados la cifra de
fallecidos alcanza ya los 4.000 o supera
los 4.000 y la cifra de personas con el
esquema completo de vacunación alcanza
el 21 57 por ciento de la población
estas son cifras del 8 de octubre que
son las últimas cifras las más
actualizadas que registra este país
y precisamente en venezuela entró en
vigor una medida de semáforo pero qué
tal resultó vamos a conectar en caracas
con nicole kolster para conocer más
detalles nicole gracias por acompañarnos
hoy en el programa y bueno comienzo
preguntarlo preguntándole por el balance
que hacen las autoridades de esta medida
santiago saludos desde caracas hasta
ahora este semáforo de acceso es un plan
piloto que se estaría realizando en unos
300 restaurantes de acá
según lo que han informado las
autoridades nosotros sí hemos hecho un
recorrido por algunos establecimientos y
aún no hemos encontrado ninguno de estos
operativos sin embargo el gobierno ha
dicho que el semáforo hobbit comenzará a
funcionar en mayor medida el primero de
noviembre cuando también inicia una
flexibilización general en venezuela la
vicepresidenta del cid rodríguez detalló
hace unos días que detectaron durante la
aplicación de una de estas pruebas
piloto que 2% de las personas que
querían entrar a restaurantes tenían
coronavirus mientras que 55% se habían
vacunado y cómo funciona este plan pues
las autoridades han explicado que en las
entradas de los restaurantes y otros
sitios públicos esta era una especie de
portero con un celular revisando los
datos de las personas que desean
ingresar al establecimiento para
verificar si está o no contagiado con el
virus y si ha sido o no vacunado donde
los revisan en una plataforma denominada
sistema patria es una web que el
gobierno utiliza para entregar ayudas
sociales y dónde todos los venezolanos
están o quieren registrarse no queda
claro cómo funcionará este plan en la
provincia que está bastante golpeada en
cuanto a conectividad conexión a
internet y constantes fallas eléctricas
nicole quiero hablar de las cifras ya
las mencionaba yo más de 390.000 casos y
tal parece que las cifras se incrementan
en las últimas semanas
de santiago a inicios de mes venezuela
entró en la tercera ola de contar serían
397.000 370 casos registrados en 585
días de pandemia con un promedio de las
últimas semanas que va de 800 a 1.500
casos diarios registrados pero hay que
recordar que estas cifras oficiales han
sido cuestionadas por distintos
organismos independientes por la
academia nacional de medicina es también
por considerar que existe un elevado su
registro de casos en el país pero en
efecto podemos comentar que en estas
últimas semanas si hemos visto un mayor
número de solicitudes en las redes
sociales de personas pidiendo ayuda para
costear tratamientos relacionados al
cómic 19 así como también peticiones de
cupos en hospitales por falta de camas
en las unidades de cuidados intensivos
esto podría servir como especie de un
termómetro para evaluar la situación
nunca así similar a la reportada en
marzo cuando inició la segunda ola por
kobe 19 en este país
y para el cierre de este contacto
hablemos de la vacunación van a comenzar
los procedimientos de vacunación en los
mayores de 12 años allí en venezuela
si te comento que el proceso de
vacunación se ha acelerado este último
mes con la llegada al país a través del
mecanismo kóvacs de varios lotes de
vacunas que incluyen la es pública en
las y novak y las tino farc según ha
dicho al gobierno 56 por ciento de la
población está ya
y aspira a tener el 70 por ciento de la
población inmunizada para finales de mes
aunque no se ha aclarado si esto incluye
únicamente a las personas que ya
completaron su inmunización oa quienes
tienen una sola dosis el gobierno
también dijo que este lunes iniciará la
vacunación de niños mayores de 12 años
pero no detalló cómo será el proceso ni
qué fármaco será utilizado el presidente
de maduro también espera recibir unas 16
millones de dosis de la cubana abdalá
antes de que finalice el año ha dicho
que venezuela también comenzará a
producir esta vacuna en una empresa
pública del país a partir de enero
nicole muchas gracias por este
completísimo reporte desde la ciudad de
caracas vamos a cambiar de país en
cuestión de días entrará en vigor en
república dominicana la medida que
establece también el uso de una tarjeta
de vacunación que será un requisito para
poder acceder al transporte público a
los espacios públicos también para ir a
trabajar y estudiar obviamente esto
provocó diferentes discrepancias entre
los ciudadanos
la tarjeta de vacunación contra el co el
19 se volvió un requisito en la
república dominicana debido a una
iniciativa del ministerio de salud
pública de este país
las personas mayores de 12 años que no
hayan recibido el esquema completo de
vacunación no podrán asistir a sus
centros de trabajo de estudios o de ocio
y tampoco podrán utilizar el transporte
público sin embargo no será un requisito
para ingresar a los centros de salud
públicos y privados y las iglesias así
como tampoco para los turistas
esta medida generó un efecto inmediato
entre la población
informamos este miércoles que en el país
persiste la demanda de vacunación
aplicándose cifras récord los días 18 y
19 del presente mes con 116 y 124 mil
inmunizados respectivamente con primera
segunda y tercera dosis de vacuna según
la organización hardware oudín data más
del 47% de la población dominicana que
cuenta con más de 10 millones de
habitantes ya tiene el esquema completo
de la vacunación a pesar de que la
medida ha tenido un impacto positivo ha
generado diferencias entre algunos
ciudadanos
bákula
porque obligado
y no puede comprar
se muestra en una tarjeta
de vacunación es una prueba de la pecera
porque yo lo que tengo es una foto
de la pc realizada negativo y él me dice
que si tiene más de una semana no puedo
acceder a el ministerio de la salud
pública advirtió que la falsificación de
la tarjeta de vacunación conllevará al
sometimiento judicial y les dejo otra
cifra destacada 115 mil trabajadores de
la salud que están en la primera línea
de lucha contra el joven 19 han
fallecido a lo largo de la pandemia de
kobe 19 así lo anunció el director de la
o ms veamos un nuevo documento de
trabajo de la oms se estima que 15 mil
trabajadores de la salud uts mb francos
pueden haber muerto por kobe 19 entre
enero de 2020 y mayo de este año y
brevemente les presento otras noticias
destacadas de la semana aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa la farmacéutica
pfiezer by antich indicó que tras hacer
seguimientos e investigaciones puedo
establecer que la inoculación de una
tercera dosis de su vacuna protege hasta
con un 95 punto 6 por ciento contra el
cob y 19 también brevemente les cuento
que las autoridades de bolivia dieron
inicio a la inoculación precisamente de
la tercera dosis de las vacunas contra
el cob y 19 y brevemente también les
cuento que en guate están presentando
allí un notable descenso en el número de
casos de kobe 19 después de que este
país fuera azotado por una tercera ola
que duró poco más de cuatro meses
en la ciudad de buenos aires la capital
de argentina la mascarilla dejó de ser
obligatoria en los espacios abiertos la
eliminación de esta medida tiene lugar
después de que cerca del 70% de la
capital ya estuviera con un esquema
completo de inoculación
buenos aires- respira sin mascarilla
desde este miércoles los porteños podrán
ejercitarse dar paseos por los parques y
reunirse en espacios abiertos tal como
lo hacían antes de la pandemia para la
verdad para mí no siento que ya sería ya
la hora que siento que es algo que se
puede sostener siempre y cuando se tomen
otras medidas por lo menos en espacios
reducidos estamos entrando en cierta
normalidad pero no en la total
normalidad por lo tanto yo un tiempito
más lo voy a usar ahora que vengo a un
espacio abierto me lo voy a sacar porque
me doy cuenta que me hace bien
oxigenarme sin embargo otros siguen
escépticos creo que es una tontería para
no decir otra cosa en este momento que
estamos un poquito mejor que antes decir
no ya está ya no tienes que usar más
la decisión fue tomada debido al avance
de la vacunación en donde 70% de la
población de buenos aires- ya tiene la
pauta completa en la última semana la
ciudad registró una media de 142
contagios y la ocupación de las camas de
cuidados intensivos destinadas a los
contagiados de coronavirus están en su
piso histórico con solo un 3.2 por
ciento gracias las autoridades
bonaerenses piden no relajarse ahora yo
les pido que sigamos cuidando nos y que
sigamos usando el tapabocas cuando es
necesario el levantamiento de la medida
sea en un momento en el que el gobierno
argentino busca implementar su plan de
apertura que pretende reactivar la
economía del país el próximo paso será
la reapertura de las fronteras para
turistas de todo el mundo el primero de
noviembre y ahora demos un vistazo a
otras noticias relacionadas con el kobe
19 destacadas en redes eeuu alcanzó 200
millones de vacunas donadas contra el
jove y 19 como parte de su campaña de
vacunación global mientras que a nivel
nacional la administración impulsa la
dosis de refuerzo las dosis donadas
incluyen más de 120 millones de
excedentes de las reservas de vacunas el
país más de 100 territorios han recibido
vacunas de estados unidos el salvador
habilita la vacunación contra el cob y
19 para extranjeros así lo anunció al
presidente en allí bukele que indicó que
la medida también cobija a las personas
que vivan en el país y que tengan
estatus irregular también para los
turistas que sólo deberán presentar su
pasaporte y serán vacunados y burundi
comienza a vacunar contra el kobe 19 y
destacamos esta noticia porque este país
africano recibió apenas esta semana el
primer lote de 500 mil vacunas
scinopharm para comenzar a administrar
las entre los ciudadanos de manera
voluntaria esto demuestra que
hay una disparidad en el otorgamiento de
vacunas a través del sistema kóvacs diez
meses después de haber empezado a
vacunar en américa este país comenzó su
proceso
es todo por esta semana aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa nos vemos la
próxima semana con más noticias
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
siga con la programación de france 24
hasta entonces
[Música]